we're less scared because  this uh earthly life  is an is only a blip in terms of the  total life  this would sort of apply to everything  like seat belts  taking antibiotics when you have a sinus  infection or strep throat and yet most  of these people do these things there  are some like i know christian science  is very much uh skeptical of medication  and sort of traditional treatment etc  but this applies to a lot of different  things that most of them do  but if you're really going to take this  approach you should really take it fully  don't take the mealy-mouthed approach  don't go to the hospital when you get  sick right go to church and pray or even  don't do anything because you're going  to more quickly get to that eternal  afterlife if you die from whatever is  afflicting you